before doing more examples with snell's
law which essentially amount to some
math problems what i want to do is get
an intuitive understanding for why this
straw looks bent in this picture right
over here to do that let me just draw a
simplified version of that of that
picture so let's draw this is the cup
right over here we'll do a side profile
of the cup
so this is
a side profile of this glass right over
here
it's the best that i can draw it and
then let me draw the actual straw so i'm
going to first draw the straw where it
actually is so it's coming in off the
side of the cup and the straw is
actually not bending it goes to the
bottom of the cup just like that
and then it goes
up like that and then it goes slightly
above it and then it actually does bend
up here up here right over here and then
the straw actually does bend but that is
irrelevant to what we want to talk about
what i want to do in this video is talk
about why when we look over here when we
look over here why does it look like the
straw got bent and it all comes out of
the refraction of the light as the light
from the straw down here changes as it
goes from one medium to another now we
know from refraction indices or just in
general that light moves slower in water
than it does in air so it's slower
slower in water and faster in air
and faster
in air so let's think about what's going
to happen let's think about what's going
to happen let me draw two points of let
me draw two rays that are coming from
this point on the straw right over here
so if i draw one ray
one ray right over here so i'm just
going to pick an arbitrary direction
so if i pick one ray just like that
now when it goes from the slower medium
to the faster medium what's going to
happen to it it's at a slight angle here
so the left side of the ray is going to
end up in the air before the right side
and i'm just using this as a as a way of
you know the i'm using the car example
to kind of think about which way this
light is going to bend so if you
visualize it as a car or sometimes
people visualize as a marching band the
left side of the marching band is going
to get out before the right side is
going to start moving faster so this is
going to turn to the right
so it's going to turn to the right
now let me do another ray
so let me do another array that's coming
from that same point
let me i don't want it to go right along
the straw so another ray just like that
it will also turn to the right so it is
also going to turn to the right
now if someone's eye
if someone's eye is right over here so
that's your eye that's the eyelashes
that's someone's eye you can even draw
their nose and all the rest if they're
looking down where does it look like
these two light rays let's say their eye
is big enough that it captured both of
these rays where does it look like these
two rays are coming from
so if you trace both of these rays back
if you just say assume that there was a
line here that's what our eyes and our
brains do if you assume that whatever
direction this ray is currently going it
is array that is the direction it came
from and same thing for this magenta ray
and this magenta ray just like that it
would look to this observer that this
point on the straw is actually right
over there and it would look and if you
kept doing that for a bunch of points on
the straw it would look like this point
on the straw is actually right over here
it would look like we could do it for
this point on the straw it would look
like that point in the straw is actually
right over here so to this observer the
straw would look like this
it would look like it would look like
something
it would look
it would look like
it would look something
like that it would look bent this part
would the even though the light from
here is going up and then up and then it
moves out because it gets bent when you
converge it back it would converge to
this just like we saw with that first
point the light from this point when it
goes out and gets bent if you were to
just extrapolate backwards from their
new directions you get to that point so
to this observer this point on the straw
will look to be right over here even
though the light was emitted down here
and that's why the straw actually looks
bent white actually it looks bent so
this is all really just because of
refraction from going from a slower
medium to a faster one so hopefully you
find that a little bit interesting the
next video we'll actually do some
examples with snell's law just to get
ourselves comfortable with the
mathematics